- [Voiceover] If you up all of the spots
on these dominoes, there are 63 spots.
So if you counted all of these dots,
they're telling us that would be 63.
So we don't have to do that.
And then they tell us,
that is 42 more spots
than the total number of
spots on a six sided die.
So they're saying if you
took a six sided die,
so a six sided die, might
look something like this.
It's a cube, it might have one dot
and then it might have
three and then over here
it might have maybe two
and so if you count up
all of these dots, the ones we see
and then the ones on
the other side as well,
that's the number of
spots on a six sided die.
Now what they're saying
is that the 63 spots,
they said if you add up all the spots
on these dominoes there is 63.
And they're saying that is 42 more spots
than the total number of
spots on a six sided die.
Let's now figure out how many spots
are on a six sided die.
The first thing you should
always ask yourselves
is what they're asking for.
Is this going to be more or less
than the number of spots that
you have on these dominoes?
You might say, "Hey, I'm reading 42 more
"I see this word more, there
must be 42 more spots."
But you have to be very,
very, very, very careful.
Whenever you do a word problem,
don't just look for words and say
"Oh it's more I'll add or if
it's fewer I'll subtract."
Because that's not going
to be the case always.
You really need to think about
what is the problem asking for?
Because they're saying that
this 63 dots right over here
that is 42 more than the
total number of spots
on a six sided die.
Another way of thinking about it is,
if you took the number of
spots on a six sided die
that's what they're asking for.
So if we say that's question mark.
If you took the number of
spots on a six sided die
and you had 42 more than that,
then that is going to be equal to
the number of spots on these dominoes
and they tell us that is 63.
The number of spots on a
six sided die plus 42 is 63
or 63 spots is 42 more
spots than the total
number of spots on a six sided die.
Always think about what they're saying.
So now we can try to figure out
what this question mark is.
Well if question mark
plus 42 is equal to 63,
that's the same thing as
saying that question mark
is equal to 63,
63 minus 42.
So what's that going to be?
We can calculate it.
So 63, six tens three ones.
42, four tens and two ones.
We want to subtract that, and when we do
we're going to figure
out the number of spots
on the six sided die.
We'll go to ones place, three ones
minus two ones is one one.
Six tens minus four
tens, those are two tens.
So two tens and one one that's 21 spots.
21 spots on a six sided die.